paris geht gerade schlafen hier beginnt
die rushhour
der größte großmarkt der welt
1,7 millionen tonnen verkaufte waren
täglich
eine stadt innerhalb der stadt mit engen
zeitplan und straffer organisation
[Musik]
geht etwas schief droht das chaos du
wirst zwei stunden zu spät ganz schlecht
ein wahrer stress job für rund 13.000
menschen
viel arbeit wenig schlaf über preise
diskutiere ich noch niemals der
jahresumsatz 9 milliarden euro
18 millionen besucher das geht nur mit
klaren regeln
wo ist dein anzug
der großmarkt
[Musik]
der größte großmarkt der welt liegt
strategisch günstig im süden von paris
bis zum zentrum sind es nur 13 kilometer
der flughafen orly und ein wichtiges
autobahnkreuz liegen gleich nebenan
die fläche des marktes beträgt 2 134
hektar größer als das fürstentum monaco
bei einbruch der nacht geht es los die
ersten trucks steuern den pavillon a4 an
einer der größten für schalen europas
sie die von meeresfrüchte aus der ganzen
welt
jeden abend halten mehrere hundert
laster an den laderampen vor dem
pavillon
[Musik]
23 uhr eine spezialfirma transportiert
die wertvolle fracht zu den marktständen
[Musik]
jetzt beginnt der arbeitstag von pascal
buffet oder genauer gesagt die arbeit
macht
buffet ist einer von 24 großhändlern in
der halle heute bekommt er vier tonnen
frischen fisch geliefert und die gilt es
so schnell wie möglich an den mann oder
die frau zu bringen
wenn du fisch verkaufen willst bist du
hier richtig dies ist eine mächtige
drehscheibe wir beliefern halb
frankreich und die benachbarten länder
der fischmarkt hat keine lagerhallen die
sind überflüssig denn buffet muss seine
ware ohnehin innerhalb von zwei tagen
verkaufen
die kunden wollen nur ganz frischen
fisch
danach muss die preise senken
[Musik]
die ersten kunden kommen in zwei stunden
bis dahin muss alles fertig sein
können sie die daneben stellen das sind
rot brassen
die fee ist voll in seinem element
fische exklusiv aus frankreich
da haben wir fantastischen hecht
ist nicht mit netzen gefangen sondern
vom boot aus vor weniger als 48 stunden
super frisch
und hier haben wir wunderbaren lachs mit
kopf und
wunderschöne gold passen
im konkurrenzkampf mit den anderen
herstellern 10 vor allem frische und
qualität
jeder großhändler hat sein eigenes
festgelegtes areal hier markiert durch
die blauen linien
die gelben linien markieren die fläche
wo neue ware angeliefert und verkaufte
ware abgeholt wird
knapp 100.000 tonnen fisch pro jahr das
macht einen umsatz von 914 millionen
euro allein in paris 4
[Musik]
möglich ist so ein großes geschäft nur
dank der perfekten organisation die
dahintersteckt
der markt öffnet kurz vor mitternacht so
ist garantiert dass die kunden bis zum
frühen morgen zurück in paris sein
können
an den toren war die das fahrzeug
registriert
23.000 pro nacht
um staus zu vermeiden ist der markt in
verschiedene sektoren aufgeteilt
jede kategorie hat ihren eigenen bereich
mit mehreren halb es gibt fisch
fleisch
milchprodukte obst und gemüse und blumen
so müssen kunden und lieferanten jeweils
nur einen sektor an steuern
der verkehr fließt zunächst über eine
hauptstraße dann verteilt er sie schnell
auf die einzelnen bereiche
damit kein chaos entsteht öffnet jeder
sektor zu einer anderen zeit so hat
jeder bereich seine eigene rush hour und
der ansturm in den toren wird
gleichmäßig über die nacht verteilt
[Musik]
diese trucks steuern einer der fünf
fleisch allen an im pavillon v1
[Musik]
halb zwei
in minuten intervallen hatten die trucks
in den ladezonen der flaschen die
ranken sind so gebaut dass die kühlkette
während das be und entladen geschlossen
bleibt fleisch muss schließlich stets
kühl gelagert werden deshalb ist die
halle 4 grad kalt
ein einziger riesiger kühlschrank
[Musik]
unter der hallendecke verläuft ein
system aus schienen und hagen nur so
kann die transporteure ganze rinder
schweine und lämmer im eiltempo zu den
großhändlern bringen
[Musik]
270.000 tonnen fleisch pro jahr
fleisch großhändler christophe de france
kommt um kurz vor zwei zur arbeit
[Musik]
er hat seinen stand schon seit über 20
jahren
hier kennt jeder jeden
vor ihm liegt eine lange und harte
nachtschicht wie jede nacht
normalerweise fange ich morgens um 1 an
und bleibt ist mittag manchmal aber auch
bis drei uhr nachmittags
zusammen mit seinem partner verkauft die
branche sechs bis zehn tonnen fleisch
pro nacht rund
3500 tonnen pro jahr
an seinem stand hängen einige
prachtstücke
und das ist nur die bereits vorrätige
ware
die große lieferung des tages kommt erst
noch
wir sind der größte markt der welt
größer geht es nicht
schneit das land zu recht die knochen
sind schon raus
20 metzger arbeiten für die branche und
seinen partner
ein knochenjob
nacht für nacht in der kälte
im moment bereiten sie eine lieferung
für einen stammkunden vor
dem porsche beliefert hauptsächlich
pariser hotels und spitzenrestaurants
natürlich nur mit erstklassiger qualität
das ist viel
das ganze stück hier
das ist der rücken
daraus machen wir es zum beispiel unsere
code lacken steak und rumpsteak
hier ist die keule
da bist du
bist ganz runter
[Musik]
unser geschäft ist vertrauenssache wir
haben viele langjährige stammkunden
wir tun alles um sie zufriedenzustellen
dazu gehört auch schon sehr früh da zu
sein und den größten teil der arbeit zu
erledigen bevor es hektisch wird
in rossis warten die konten nicht gern
aber genau dieses problem hat die
branche heute nacht
auf dem areal des großmarktes gibt es
1200 firmen mit rund 13.000 arbeitern
und angestellten der
markt ist so groß wie 330 fußballfelder
in den fünfzig hallen sind neben dem
verkauf auch die logistik lagerflächen
und dienstleistungsbetriebe
untergebracht
im verwaltungsgebäude befindet sich auch
die sicherheitsleitstelle mit ihrer
eigenen feuerwehr
hier laufen alle fäden zusammen
30 feuerwehrleute arbeiten exklusiv für
den markt
[Musik]
wir haben ein sehr effektives
sicherheitssystem
wenn irgendetwas passiert sind wir
sofort da
das ganze gelände wird rund um die uhr
überwacht feuermelder und
sprinkleranlagen sind computergesteuert
[Musik]
wir wissen immer genau welcher
feuermelder einen alarm ausgelöst hat
dahin schicken wir dann die feuerwehr
[Musik]
allein in der halle für obst und gemüse
hat die sprinkleranlage 1 110 kilometer
langes rohrsystem
die angst vor feuer ist das eine noch
größer aber ist die angst vor einem
ausfall der kühlanlage
dann wären lebensmittel im wert von
mehreren millionen euro gedroht
deshalb hat die sicherheitsleitstelle
ständig ein auge auf das kühlsystem
beim fleisch etwa muss die temperatur
immer bei vier grad celsius liegen
[Musik]
den fisch genügen dagegen 13 grad
das liegt daran dass fisch zusätzlich in
eis gelagert wird
[Musik]
der großmarkt braucht jede menge eis
damit es keinen engpass gibt wird das
eis direkt vor ort produziert in einem
speziellen kühlturm gleich neben der
fischhalle
[Musik]
darin befindet sich ein gigantischer mit
wasser gefüllter zylinder
durch die äußeren rohre strömt harmonie
und während es kondensiert wenn zieht
das schlüssige gas dem ziel in der wärme
dadurch kühlen sich die metallwände ab
so bildet sich eis das durch die
rotation abgeschafft wird es sammelt
sich am boden und wird sofort
abtransportiert
kurz vor 2 uhr sky live hat alles
vorbereitet gleich kommen die kunden
zeit für einen letzten qualitätscheck
[Musik]
die kiemen müssen schön rot sein
und die schuppen schön flach das ist
sehr wichtig
der fisch ist frisch und lässt nichts zu
wünschen übrig
jetzt geht es los
die ersten kunden sind da
der weg 3,3
der knapp über zwei
3,3 schreibt das auf natürlich habe ich
beim preis einen gewissen spielraum aber
keinen großen einige meiner lieferanten
kaufen und verkaufen zum festpreis dann
muss auch ich zum festpreis verkaufen
ein bisschen verhandeln ist drin aber
höchstens 50 cent die gewinnspanne ist
sehr klein
muss in kurzer zeit viel verkaufen
wir schreiben den kundennummern auf
die ware geht dann in den abhol bereich
die kunden müssen nach dem bezahlen
nicht noch mal herkommen
am anderen ende der halle starten cusack
und sebastian kopp ihren rundgang die
beiden sicherheitsleute achten darauf
dass sich die händler an die
vorschriften halten
ich hab's ja schon mal gesagt
achte auch die linie
der händler hat die grenze überschritten
das ist verboten und kann bestraft
werden
[Musik]
die händler zahlen für eine bestimmte
fläche wenn sie sich daran nicht halten
ist das unfair gegenüber den anderen
ungefähr 90 prozent halten sich aber an
die regeln die nachbarn beschweren sich
schon wenn sie es nicht tun
hinter die blaue linie okay
die inspektoren nehmen alles sehr genau
besonders wenn es um hygiene geht
[Musik]
hallo
sie müssen ihren weißen anzug tragen ich
weiß ich bin grad erst gekommen
letzte warnung okay
wir achten darauf dass niemand gegen die
vorschrift verstößt
die regeln gelten für jeden wenn wir ihm
noch mal erwischen zahlt er 68 euro
strafe wir treffen alle möglichen
vorkehrungen und wenn es sein muss
greifen wir hart durch eine verwarnung
kann bis zu 450 euro kosten
30 inspektoren arbeiten rund um die uhr
in allen sektoren des großmarktes
[Musik]
kurz vor 3
christoph die plage wartet immer noch
auf seiner lieferung science lab an der
verladerampe endet in fünf minuten ohne
rampe kann er nicht abladen
[Musik]
abgeladen wird zwischen mitternacht und
drei uhr
für uns wird es jetzt knapp
von drei bis elf ist ja alles für die
kunden reserviert
keine ahnung was wir jetzt machen
die slots an der rampe sind durch
getaktet in ein paar minuten fährt der
nächste trog vor
wenn die branche nicht kurzfristig eine
andere rampe buchen kann muss der
verspätete laster wieder umdrehen
während der porsche zur untätigkeit
verdammt ist macht die konkurrenz das
große geschäft
in dieser halle werden nur in rain
verkauft
sascha kanu ist mit seinem team bei der
arbeit
pro nacht zerlegen sie drei und hat cups
köpfe wie am fließband
kalbsbäckchen und zunge gelten in
frankreich als wahre delikatessen
kein wunder dass der großhändler vor
allem das luxussegment beliefert
die knochen und das fett essen wir nicht
nur in die säle tine und die haut
das sind die delikatessen bei uns kaufen
viele politiker jacques chirac präsident
roland miosga und präsident max
während das geschäft in der fleisch
halle bereits in vollem gange ist kommen
die waren hier gerade erst an
der großmarkt ist ans schienennetz
angeschlossen und hat einen eigenen
bahnhof so können die lebensmittel auch
per bahn transportiert werden am bahnhof
kommen hauptsächlich obst und gemüse
die leicht verderbliche ware muss
schnellstens weitertransportiert werden
140 transport logistik und lagerung
unternehmen kümmern sich um den
warenverkehr am bahnhof
der größte teil der angelieferten
produkte landet in einer der hallen für
obst und gemüse
in diesem sektor gibt es die meisten
hallen insgesamt zehn
mehr als 1,2 millionen tonnen obst und
gemüse werden pro jahr verkauft viermal
so viel wie fleisch
anders als bei fisch und fleisch gibt es
hier keine kühlung deshalb wissen die
händler ihre ware vor der schicht
reinholen und wie danach zurück in die
gekühlten lagerräume bringen
[Musik]
der ruß großmarkt wird von der
halbstaatlichen firma solaris betrieben
sie mag es vermietet die flächen an die
großhändler
die mieter hängt von der zahl der
rolltore und der benötigten lagerfläche
ab
die fahrer sorgt für transport und
infrastruktur die händler können sich so
ganz auf ihr geschäft konzentrieren
[Musik]
halb vier
obst großhändler die juli checkt seiner
ware
diese roten kirschen haben wir dieses
jahr zum ersten mal
der glanz ist ein qualitätsmerkmal
das sind wirklich schöne kirchen fast
ohne druckstellen
in dieser qualität hält sich hier in der
halle normalerweise für acht bis zehn
tagen
juli gilt als spezialist er verkauft nur
ausgesuchte produkte von erlesener
qualität
nicola wir müssen die palette von den
kirchen zurückbringen
das war kommt weg dann kommen die
kirschen dahin
julis wertvolle schätze lagern im keller
dort ist es wesentlich kühler das
verlangsamt den reifeprozess der früchte
[Musik]
der keller verschafft juni außerdem
größeren spielraum bei der
preisgestaltung
[Musik]
die himbeeren sind heute morgen gekommen
wir haben nur ein partner von oben in
der auslage das meiste lagern wie hier
und die himbeeren sind relativ teuer
wenn die kunden wissen dass wir so viele
haben würden sie unseren preis nicht
bezahlen
der preiskampf ist hart und die
konkurrenz unerbittlich
der markt ist während der letzten zehn
jahre dramatisch gewachsen die
geschichte des großmarkts reicht zurück
bis ins fünfte jahrhundert
ursprünglichen pariser zentrum
angesiedelt platz der in den 50er jahren
des letzten jahrhunderts allmählich aus
den nähten
[Musik]
1960 verfügt präsident schade goal
persönlich dass der markt an die
peripherie umziehen soll
das aufwendige projekt gilt als umzug
des jahrhunderts
nur eine woche später folgt die
wiedereröffnung
1973 schließt sich der pariser
fleischmarkt an
[Musik]
bis heute ist der internationale
großmarkt in orange ist der größte
seiner art der jahresumsatz von 9 1
milliarden euro wird mit fleisch fisch
obst und gemüse milch und bio produkten
sowie blumen erzählt
aus der französischen metropole ist der
markt nicht mehr wegzudenken 65 prozent
seiner produkte bleiben in paris 20
prozent gehen ins übrige land und der
rest ins ausland
[Musik]
34 fleisch groß hinter dem porsche
wartet jetzt schon seit zwei stunden auf
seine lieferung
das geht gar nicht was soll ich meinen
kunden sagen
wegen der verspätung hatte branche eine
zusätzliche laderampe gebucht aber auch
die ist schon wieder vergeben
da steht ein geflügelter
der slot gehört jetzt ihm
der wagen ist jetzt da aber ich brauche
einen neustart
wir müssen das jetzt irgendwie
hinkriegen
ein transporter verlässt die laderampe
aber der nächste track wartet schon
ich habe bei der zentrale angerufen und
nach einem slot gefragt ich kenne die
ganz gut wir trinken man zwar kaffee
zusammen
leider sind auf der warteliste noch zwei
vor mir dran sie wollen sehen was sie
für mich tun können
wenigstens ist der traktor
zweieinhalb stunden zu spät
anderthalb stunden früher wäre noch okay
gewesen aber jetzt nicht mehr
zurück
wenn der 40 tonnen truck nicht bald
abladen darf gibt es einen super stau
[Musik]
wenn wir unseren slot verpassen haben
wir jedes mal ein großes durcheinander
vor einer stunde wäre es auch okay
gewesen aber jetzt
[Musik]
15 minuten später hat der truck endlich
seinen platz die branche ist erleichtert
bordeaux
das fleisch wird ausgeladen und muss so
schnell wie möglich auf die
verkaufsfläche
die konnten rossis haben alle eines
gemeinsam wir haben keine zeit
[Musik]
wir sind auch für mich
die aufkleber sind manchmal komisch
bizarr
ich schaue mir die farbe
die knochen
trotz des zeitdrucks musste das fleisch
gründlich prüfen erst dann darf es in
den verkauf
[Musik]
wenn er es während der öffnungszeit
nicht los wird muss er sich direkt an
seine kunden wenden das bedeutet mal
wieder überstunden die ewigen
nachtschichten dazu tag schichten dem
büro und ständiger schlafmangel sind für
die branche das schlimmste an seinem job
wer hier arbeitet muss glücklich
verheiratet sein du brauchst eine
verständnisvolle frau sonst wird's
kompliziert
ich krieg nur wenig schlaf
ich komm nach hause schlaf eine halbe
stunde auf dem sofa dann geht es weiter
mein sohn hat dienstags fußballtraining
wenn ich nicht bis 4 nach hause komme
bekomme ich nur eine halbe stunde schlaf
bevor ich ihn hinbringen
manchmal musst du einfach für deine
familie da sein sonst was du eines tages
auf und dein sohn kennt dich nicht mehr
[Musik]
und während der plausch und sein team
versuchen die verlorene zeit wieder
aufzuholen
machen die kollegen von der konkurrenz
eine kurze pause
morgens um fünf
im café sauer über herrscht hochbetrieb
es hat von 12 uhr abends ist zwölf uhr
mittags geöffnet eine oase im chaos der
nachtschicht
am anfang war es hart ich brauchte eine
ganze woche bis ich halbwegs verstand
was hier abgeht dabei habe ich vorher
als frachtführer gearbeitet da war ich
noch im vorteil für anfänger ist es ganz
schön kompliziert
der großmarkt ist tatsächlich so etwas
wie eine eigene stadt in der stadt
hier gibt es den besten fisch weit und
breit früher bin ich ans meer gefahren
und hat direkt bei den fischern gekauft
aber oft bekam ich nicht was ich suchte
hier gibt es alles lachs garnelen
einfach alles
hier kannst du dir dein fleisch selbst
aussuchen
du erkennst sofort die qualität
deshalb komme ich gerne her
dass song über gehört zu den 23 bars und
restaurants auf dem markt angeblich
verkauft es mehr kaffee als ihr das
andere bistro in frankreich 3000 tassen
am tag
durch die scheibe schaut man direkt in
die waagschale so können die händler bei
einer tasse kaffee geschäfte machen und
gleichzeitig ihren stand im auge
behalten
für viele sind die kollegen zur familie
geworden kein wunder der rest von paris
hat schließlich einen ganz anderen
rhythmus
[Musik]
5 uhr und fischhändler dürfen hat schon
zwei drittel seiner ware verkauft
im schnitt sind es zwei tonnen pro tag
nicht mehr
warum wenn etwas übrig bleibt verkaufen
wir es eben am nächsten tag in der nacht
von freitag auf samstag ist bis 3 uhr
alles verkauft
ich werfe nie etwas weg
ich lebe an der küste kam aber trotzdem
zum einkaufen her qualität und auswahl
sind einfach besser
für den großen adler fisch gibt es einen
interessenten die verhandlungen sind in
vollem gange
ein bisschen teuer aber kein schlechter
preis
ich diskutiere nicht über den preis ich
verrate auch nie was ich selbst bezahlt
habe niemals
die anspannung ist mit händen zu greifen
schließlich hat auch die konkurrenz
exotischen fisch und delikatessen aus
aller welt im angebot
ich habe viele stammkunden
das verdanke ich meine großen auswahl
viele händler haben nur zwei oder drei
artikel ich habe 50 der kunde hat viele
optionen
er kommt zu mir weil es praktischer für
ihn ist
während der drei stunden öffnungszeit
bedient über 100 kunden
hubert weiger
[Musik]
in den hinteren räumen wird die ganze
nacht geschuftet
die arbeiter viele tieren pro schicht
tausende fische
red snapper lachs oder thunfisch
[Musik]
die kunden müssen keine ganzen fische
kaufen sie können sich ihren einkauf je
nach wunsch präparieren lassen
[Musik]
die inspektoren kontrollieren der bald
den außenbereich des pavillons
hier kommt normalerweise die ware an im
moment liefern wir aber aus 200 tonnen
pro nacht
in der vorweihnachtszeit sind es fünf
bis 600 tonnen jede nacht
pro jahr kommen über 94.000 tonnen fisch
zusammen
damit es nicht zum totalen chaos führt
gibt es in jeans ein simples aber höchst
effizientes verkaufssysteme
[Musik]
jedem kunden wird im äußeren gang ein
nummerierte platz zugeteilt die nummer
schreibt der verkäufer auf einen zettel
die verkaufsteams bringen die ware dann
zum platz mit der dazugehörigen nummer
die kunden laden die ware selbst in ihre
fahrzeuge
[Musik]
der abhol bereich wird von videokameras
überwacht damit der teure fisch auch
wirklich im richtigen wagen landes
[Musik]
wir haben hier ein diebstahl problem mit
den kameras ist es besser geworden
trotzdem haben wir es noch mit naja
sagen wir
illegalen verschiebungen zu tun
heute gibt es wenig zu beanstanden
abgesehen von ein paar verwarnungen
bleibt es ruhig
wir sind ein kommerzielles unternehmen
jeder kennt seine verantwortung wenn mal
jemand aus der reihe tanzt ist es unser
job ihn an die vorschriften zu erinnern
und für ordnung zu sorgen
draußen beginnt das rennen in richtung
innenstadt
bei den milchprodukten dagegen geht es
gerade erst los
viertel vor sechs
käse so weit das auge reicht
[Musik]
auch für edwin bollier hat der
arbeitstag mitten in der nacht begonnen
seien sie nicht das sei teuer
[Gelächter]
wird zum ersten mal nach rossis kommt
bleibt entweder für einen tag oder für
immer wenn das umfeld hier akzeptierst
kommst du klar wenn du es nicht tust
bist du in schwierigkeiten
nachtarbeit ist nicht jedermanns sache
oje hat kein problem damit
er verkauft 800 tonnen eiern und 3000
tonnen käse pro jahr
für den französischen markt ziemlich
rekordverdächtig
[Musik]
warum schießt eine wichtige drehscheibe
für den großraum paris aber der druck
wächst von jahr zu jahr
wir machen um 35 auf die kunden kommen
um 5.45 und wollen um 6 wieder [ __ ]
wir haben wenig platz dies kann ich mir
expandieren schließlich liegen wir genau
zwischen dem flughafen und der autobahn
ab 7 uhr beginnt die rushhour dann wird
senken
[Musik]
noch läuft beim obst und gemüse das
geschäft aber in zwei stunden ist schoss
[Musik]
ich habe noch erdbeeren die kriegen sie
für drei euro angebot nachfrage und
qualität bestimmen den preis der
unterliegt ständigen schwankungen
händler und kunden feilschen um jeden
cent
650 kilo
frankreich
trotz der großen mengen mit den juni
jede nacht hantiert das können bis zu 30
tonnen sein kennt er die bedürfnisse
seiner kunden ganz genau
über 35 jahre so lange bis du schon hier
die
ja seit
1982 oder 83
die auswahl ist beeindruckend und
[Musik]
es gibt immer was neues
man muss auch die eigenen kunden gut
kennen
egal was ich ihr kaufe ich weiß schon zu
welchem preis ich es weiterverkaufe und
anwenden
während der eine kunde bezahlt
verhandelt juni bereits mit dem nächsten
keine sorge sie sind verpackt und gleich
da
juli gibt seine bestellung mit dem
tablet auf das geht mit abstand am
schnellsten
[Musik]
die fleischer hat ein anderes system
die händler befestigen einen zettel an
der verkauften ware während die kunden
an der zentralen kasse bezahlen bargeld
wird nicht akzeptiert dank dieser
methode können sich die händler den
platz für individuelle kassen sparen
[Musik]
wer fisch kauft bekommt einen zettel mit
einer nummer und nimmt die ware dann im
april bereich entgegen
[Musik]
natürlich sind fast alle produkte auch
online erhältlich bestellungen werden
auf dem großmarkt bearbeitet verpackt
und verschickt
einige dienstleister haben sich darauf
spezialisiert sie sorgen dafür dass
alles so schnell und effizient wie
möglich abläuft
[Musik]
zeit ist auch für milchprodukte ein
faktor allerdings gilt hier das
gegenteil die produkte werden mit der
zeit nicht schlechter sondern besser
[Musik]
willkommen in den höhlen von rossis sie
sind einmalig
unmengen von käse reifen unterhalb der
verkaufshalle
jeder leib hat einen wert von rund 1000
euro
[Musik]
es dauert vier jahre bis er verkauft
werden kann
[Musik]
schauen wir uns den mal an
so testen wir die qualität
mit einer ganz altmodischen methode
holen wir eine probe heraus
und die wird gekostet
[Musik]
der rest kommt zurück in den käse das
loch wird mit einer paste verschlossen
und der leib versiegelt
ein käse auf das tagesgeschäft anders
als bei anderen frischeprodukten der
großteil wird nicht in der halle
verkauft sondern
online.de verschickt seine ware in die
ganze welt
[Musik]
wir exportieren nach ganz europa unsere
laster fahren nach deutschland und
osteuropa
eine spezialfirma präpariert unsere
produkte für den transport per flugzeug
wir liefern nach malaysia und in den
kongo
innerhalb von 72 stunden können wir den
käse an jeden ort der welt liefern
kurz vor 6 und dem platz stehst gleich
in letzter minute kauft ein kunde noch
schnell ein stück fleisch
viele kunden konnten nicht auch die
verspätete lieferung warten sie sind mit
leeren händen nach paris zurück gefahren
oder haben bei der konkurrenz gekauft
die branche muss sie einzeln
abtelefonieren um seine ware vielleicht
doch noch loszuwerden
kompliziert der verspätete laster hat
alles durcheinander gebracht
wir haben noch viel übrig
die leute haben woanders gekauft
kein guter tag
wir konnten nicht richtig arbeiten
normalerweise fangen wir an nehmen die
ware entgegen machen sie fertig und
verkaufen sie dann
aber das ging heute nicht wir konnten
nur wenig verkaufen weil die meisten
kunden schon weg waren
[Musik]
aber sowas passiert eben
diplom schließt seinen laden ende der
verkaufszeit aber sein arbeitstag ist
noch lange nicht vorbei
beim obst und gemüse herrscht
hochbetrieb
[Musik]
gut aus spanien nein aber freiland ganz
toll
besser als aus dem gewächshaus
die sind wirklich gut mehr habe ich
nicht
ich komme morgen wieder viel glück und
renntag an einem guten tag verkauft juli
25 bis 30 tonnen obst
und ein schuss hier in rosis gibt es ein
riesiges angebot
die konkurrenz ist gewaltig wir haben
136 großhändler einer neben dem anderen
deshalb bin ich bei der preisgestaltung
alles andere als frei um einen höheren
preis als der nachbar verlangen zu
können brauchst du ein sehr gutes
produkt bei dem alles stimmt farbe
gewicht herkunft und
wachstumsbedingungen in
so einem umfeld musst du dich jeden tag
aufs neue beweisen manche haben glück
und werden mit dem geschäft reich
wenn du nicht dumm bist lernst du aus
den fehlern der anderen und kopiert
gewisse dinge ich habe die gelegenheit
ergriffen und gut aufgepasst ich habe
hier als verkäufer angefangen und habe
jetzt mein eigenes geschäft
[Musik]
draußen vor dem obst und gemüse pavillon
werden die vielen paletten verladen
vor den ausgängen stauen sich die
fahrzeuge
[Musik]
und während drinnen noch die letzten
waren den besitzer wechseln beginn schon
das großreinemachen
[Musik]
um den müllberg in den griff zu bekommen
hat der großmarkt seine eigene
verbrennungsanlage
126 tonnen müll fallen jeden tag an
genug um mit der gewonnenen energie den
kompletten markt mit warmwasser zu
versorgen
selbst für die angrenzenden bezirke
fällt noch etwas an
auch der flughafen orly wird sie 20
seiner energie aus rossis
[Musik]
viertel nach sechs in der schale ist
fast nichts mehr los pascal hat noch
einige fische übrig
die wurden in der nacht von mittwoch auf
donnerstag gefangen
die boote kam gestern mittag an
hier geht heute nichts mehr
was die fällen nicht verkauft hat darf
er für einen tag ein lagern aber nicht
länger
heute war es ziemlich ruhig
aber wir haben gute geschäfte gemacht
einige kunden waren heute nicht da die
werden morgen kommen und freitag und
samstag steht das wochenend geschäft an
danach ist alles weg heute war ein guter
tag
der pavillon a4 schließt um 7 uhr
[Musik]
pascal buffet hat für heute schluss
im laufe der nacht wurden in rossis 250
tonnen fisch 3000 tonnen fleisch und
3900 tonnen obst und gemüse verkauft
[Musik]
der größte großmarkt der welt schließt
um kurz vor zwölf
bis zum nächsten abend in dieser
gigantischen drehscheibe am stadtrand
von paris
[Musik]